My name is Davar Ardalan and I'm the
founder and storyteller in chief of IVOW
And IVOW stands for "voices of wisdom," a vow to make sure that the future of
storytelling with artificial intelligence is culturally conscious.
Many of the stories that you might see
in newspapers or in digital stories in
the future might be generated by
machines and not journalists. This summer
it was the first time that parts of
Wimbledon were actually reported by
machines. Across six courts in Wimbledon it was actually a machine that captured
the highlight videos so the machine was
trained to understand the sound
that the audiences were making and the
reaction of the athletes and the data
around the players, and they were able to generate within 50 minutes
video packages from six different courts
at Wimbledon and share that with the
Wimbledon fan. This is an example of how machine learning is generating new
content. I was a production assistant at
NPR News in 1994 and that's what I would
have been doing. Logging tape and
listening for those highlight reels. But
the idea is that journalists are behind
the creation of them. So the
understanding of the ethics and the journalism craft that goes into
creating the storytelling templates and
also creating the infrastructure around
how to automate news. What we're doing is we're tagging data around culture
tradition and heritage and bringing
together the power of artificial
intelligence to create stories that
really anchor the public in the stories
of their traditions and cultures in new
ways. The Washington Post, New York Times,
and Reuters are all veterans at this by
this point in the last couple years and
their focus is on politics and business
and entertainment and sports. It's
exciting for us to get into this field
as people who come from a public media
background to think about also how do we capture data around culture and heritage
for communities around the world.